this is an extra special edition of PFT
ot quit hiring coaches teams we got
other things to do we can't stop
everything we're doing and rush back to
the studio we talked earlier today Chris
Sims Mike Florio here with you about the
Panthers hiring Matt rule now another
domino falls the Giants hire Patriots
special teams coordinator and for one
year receivers coach Joe judge immediate
reaction from you Chris Sims I mean a
little shocked I can't lie one I mean
from everything I knew who from people
in the NFL I thought Joe judge was
heading to Mississippi State to become
the head coach there so that was the
first thing that shocked me second off I
guess the other thing that shocked me
Mike and I don't know how you feel about
this but you know I'm just shocked by
this seemed like okay Matt rule got
hired in the Giants we get a hurry up
and hire our guy like what was the rush
I guess is what I really want to say is
the next the next thing now Joe judge I
know him I was in New England with him
he was a special teams assistant at the
time is he head coach material certainly
do I know if he was ready to take over
NFL head coaching coaching duties right
now no I have some questions about that
I definitely do yeah and I think that
there was a connection there based upon
what we've seen that the back and forth
Matt rule getting a big offer and we'll
talk about that in a minute from the
Carolina Panthers shopping it back to
the Giants for the Giants willing to
match it and you know it sounds like
each side is gonna try to make it look
like they made the choice the Giants
chose judge overruled and ruled chose
the Panthers over the Giants but it
could be that the Giants enroll wanted
to work something out and ultimately
couldn't because of money right and
David Tepper was able to get Matt rule
away from the Giants but even once you
take Matt rule out of the mix the idea
that Joe judge was the fallback is a
surprise but it's heartening because
I've been saying for a long time now
special teams coordinators should be
mentioned more often should as potential
head coaches look at John Harbaugh yeah
right you bring the whole team together
you're used to coaching guys from both
sides of the ball and you don't let
that ego takeover because you have a
system per offense or defense no you
don't need a system you just come up
with a playbook based upon who your
players are that's what Harbaugh is done
on offense with Lamar Jackson it's
worked for over a decade and I hope Joe
judge does well because if he does then
it opens the door for more special teams
coordinator well agreed with you there I
I think that this needs to be an avenue
more you know dissected into as far as
yes you don't need to be in the young
offensive genius to be a head coach in
the NFL you know you know yes we've seen
that in Bill Belichick he made his way
as the special teams coach so you know
it is interesting and from everything I
know Mike just to talk about the first
point you brought up from everything I
know from people around the NFL Matt
rule was offered this deal by the
Carolina Panthers gave the Giants the
chance to match it but as we know and
we'll talk about it more it sounds the
deal in Carolina is an epic deal I mean
I mean this we just coaches don't make
this kind of money especially first time
NFL head coaches so I think that's where
it's shocking but back to the Joe judge
thing yes I'm with you there's more to
then just X's and O's and oh I know how
to get a wide receiver open we've talked
about this over the last few weeks some
coaches can just go in there and go hey
we got to attack this I know how to hire
a great offensive coordinator or
defensive coordinator here's the
weakness of this team now you guys
figure out the game plan you know
there's a lot of coaches that have been
successful over over time doing those
type of things and also what I think is
like you know I would think the Mehra's
must have got a very strong endorsement
from Bill Belichick about Joe judge
because the Mehra's as we know there's
great respect I think there's still a
lot of communication between them and
Belichick and I know this just sounds
there just seems to me like Belichick
musta gave a very great review of Joe
judge that probably helped the Mehra's
and the Giants organization come to this
conclusion as well yeah because it is a
surprise Joe judge isn't a name that
popped up on other radar screens the
Browns weren't interested it was down to
the Browns and the Giants once the
Panthers job is filled but you know
there's value in getting your job
officially
filled and done so you can start filling
out your staff and one of the first
moves for the Giants could be if Jason
Garrett is interested talking to him
about becoming the offensive coordinator
of the New York Giants he wanted to be
the head coach he may have to settle for
this and if he wants to work this year
this may be all he can get what do you
think of Jason Garrett running an
offense it has guys like say Quan
Barkley and Daniel Jones well III don't
I got no problem with that
I get it I mean one if I'm Jason Garrett
I think this is gonna be the avenue he
has to take to repair his image a little
bit if he ever wants to be a head coach
once again show hey look at me I still
no offense I've improved my offense and
things like that yes to from the Giants
perspective and a guy like Joe judge you
know we've seen this already and in the
recent you know the recent past it's not
totally crazy you know Shawn McVeigh got
a job hey ex head coach Wade Phillips
come out here and be my defensive
coordinator takes one thing off the
plate of a guy who's a first-time head
coach so that would make sense from that
standpoint I would understand that and I
think Jason Garrett certainly smart
enough respectful enough to know his
place as the offensive coordinator and
do what the head coach asked him to do
and and try to do his best calling plays
and and with game plan design one thing
we know about Jason Garrett he will
submit to authority he did it for a
decade very true Dallas even though it
was the head coach and the idea of
working for someone considerably younger
than you as the head coach hey after
dealing with Jerry and Steven Jones he
can do anything I don't know that the
move is going to be celebrated in New
York if it happens but you know how do
you think Giants fans are gonna react to
Joe judge Chris deep down you're a
Giants fan what was your thought when
you heard that he's gonna have the job
you know I listen I know Joe judge so I
was excited just from that standpoint I
mean I got to see and be around him on a
daily basis again is another guy that
you know you don't stay in New England
and become the special teams coordinator
unless you're on top of your game and
have great energy on a day to day basis
and I mean come on how many games over
the last few years have we seen the
Patriots win or you know pull even
because
they're special teams so this is a guy
that understands the game and that's
where I'm excited now the Giants fans
IIIi think they're gonna be underwhelmed
by this I think there's gonna be a
little bit of like who what is this guy
this doesn't seem right you know why did
we make this quick and rash of a
decision I think there's gonna be a lot
of that I think the one thing though
that'll make the Giants and sleep easy
at night is okay he did come from New
England and he worked for Bill Belichick
he can't be that stupid he's got to have
something smart about them and I think
that's where they'll be able to swallow
this but I don't think this is gonna be
like a love affair or a love at first
sight type of thing and it'll be
interesting to see if we ever find out
how much Joe judge is getting paid
because it sounds like the Giants would
have had could have had rule as you
mentioned they just weren't willing to
match what David Tepper was willing to
pay to Matt rule and and that raises a
very intriguing dynamic that doesn't get
discussed discussed much I think the NFL
and the owners prefer that it never be
discussed that is how much money coaches
make and I'm told the top guys in the
sport are slightly north of 15 million a
year but it never gets communicated that
way to the league office there are
different ways of paying the money
through LLC's and whatnot so the
official number that's on file with the
league is never as high as it really is
though because they don't want a couple
of things they don't want to get the PR
flack that they're paying these guys too
much and they don't want the curve to be
blown wide open with guys like Matt rule
at the entry level getting nine million
a year with the ability to push it to
ten million a year that this is a
first-year coaches are in the range of 5
to 7 million a year this is a huge jump
huge and it's gonna and it's gonna have
ripple effects for other guys who get
hired now like it's gonna cost the
Browns more to hire a coach and what
about guys like Kyle Shanahan who have a
six year contract in place three years
in three years left he's gonna look at
Matt rule and say what the hell this
guy's making nine-minute he's never done
anything I'm taking you to the Super
Bowl potentially it's time for me to get
a raise well yeah Jed York could say to
him here under contract for three more
years Kyle sorry
yeah no you're you're right this kind of
throws everything you know for for a
loop a little bit and
I like Kyle Shanahan yeah if he goes and
wins the Super Bowl with the 49ers I'm
sure he's gonna look at his owner and be
like hey there's this guy across the
country who doesn't have as many pellets
on the horse as I do and he's making
more money than me it doesn't make sense
but you're right Mike I mean I think
this is a very unknown under-the-radar
thing in football I know a few coaches
and have known them through the years
who I know they made more money than
what the public knew or what the NFL
knew there's many avenues to pay these
head coaches a lot of these owners have
other businesses so they can also pay
them through that and it doesn't go on
the bottom line through the franchise
that way too so this has always gone on
and I get it
but you're right for the first first
time hirings you know we've seen more
towards the four and six million dollars
a year for those type of coaches to go
nine million with seven years I mean if
you sign a seven-year deal you're pretty
much guaranteed you're gonna get four
years for sure to coach that football
team no matter what happens and I know
David Tepper has got more money than he
knows what to do with but I think even a
guy like him is not gonna just give guys
some five years of free salary and fire
him after two years so that's where it's
crazy but yeah my I mean what your get
your guests like Belichick Sean Payton
Andy Reid I would think are all making
Pete Carroll Pete Carroll are all making
way more money than we really think they
are like I would think they're all north
or at least hovering around that 15
million dollar a year range right yeah
and you're right with no salary cap
there's no accountability you can pay
the guy whatever you want and you can
communicate the lower number to the
league and it's not like you're gonna
sniff around and see if you're paying
him extra right they don't care if
you're paying him extra and a couple of
other guys that I think are intriguing
in this regard Sean McVeigh who did his
extension before the season he probably
wishes he'd waited yeah laughter Matt
rule did his contract and what about
your guy Jon Gruden ten years a hundred
million dollars sounded great at the
time but he's locked in for ten freakin
years at two at an average of ten
million a year with a lot of it
back-loaded
and you know if he ever turns it around
and he got close this year and he's
being passed by by guys who are new to
coaching in the NFL and he's got a Super
Bowl ring that's the thing that can
cause some problems but that that's
that's the downside of taking security
yeah
when you take that say Matt rule could
be in the same boat he signed up for
seven years five years from now yeah
maybe maybe the market is 15 million a
year for the guys who are just getting
started I mean it's amazing to me Nick
falls all due respect is making 22
million a year if you've got 22 million
in a given year to spend are you
spending it on Nick Falls or Bill
Belichick yeah that's a no-brainer
that's right it's a no-brainer you're
exactly right and that's how it should
be justified yeah I mean a lot of these
coaches they're the stars of the
franchise in a lot of ways so you know
and it's hard you know to ask that okay
start the franchise you're the general
of all my players and everything like
that
but meanwhile you're gonna coach a guy
who's making three times more than you
or four times more than you and all that
that doesn't make sense either so yeah I
mean they should be paid more or at
least something comparable or
respectable as compared to what guys in
the locker room are being paid as well I
understand they're never gonna get
quarterback money and 35 million dollars
a year or anything like that but they
also don't want to look up and go and
Men the backup linebackers making as
much as me and he's you know he's
working in this building like 20% of the
time as compared to my you know 110 hour
weeks that I put in as a head coach so I
get it I'm not mad these coaches make
great sacrifices that way just crazy to
see a first-timer out of college come in
and get this type of contract okay so
before we powered down and inevitably
wait for the Browns to announce their
next head Josh later let's spend a
minute or two talking about what we
think the Browns will do moving forward
on one hand look it was good for them
they weren't in the mat role business
because Matt rule wasn't in the
Cleveland Browns business and they
weren't gonna hire Joe judge so you
don't you the only guy they lost that
they were interested in so far this
cycle was Mike McCarthy right so they
get their pick of who's left the music
has stopped and there's one chair
without an ass in it the problem is
these other
laughs are gonna start to fill up so you
better get a coach in place who can
convince guys to join him in Cleveland
that's right instead of Joe judge in New
York or Matt rule in Charlotte that is a
little of the yes you're right part of
this race now is the arms race to get
assistance do things like that you know
to me Mike you've heard my thoughts on
this I think it should be josh mcdaniels
i hope it is josh mcdaniels it makes the
most sense I mean from so many different
angles I mean Josh you're talking about
an organization that's dysfunctional and
not stable and McDaniels is the very
opposite of that you know he's very
functional been part of a functional
organization very stable organization
that understands how to run and be
stable consistently day in day out year
after year and he's from Cleveland who
better to reverse the curse in Cleveland
than a guy from Cleveland and we know he
like Baker Mayfield they're just all the
things line up to me to where I just I
would be shocked if something somewhere
here in the next 24 hours we don't hear
Josh McDaniels the head coach at the
Cleveland Browns and here's the thing if
I'm negotiating the contract on behalf
of Josh McDaniels obviously I'm looking
for 10 million a year at a minimum to
start and I want at least six years
fully guaranteed ooff said I want the
Kyle Shanahan term right so I'm not
gonna get thrown out the door
prematurely by Jimmy Haslam who changes
his mind as often as I change my socks
if not more frequently as the case may
be depending upon how nice the socks are
but I I also want to have built in there
and I think coaches need to start
thinking about this the ability to make
more based on what other coaches are
making it again the problem is so much
of this stuff is off the books I think
maybe the time is come for it to be no
longer off the books they need to report
real numbers of the NFL because I think
it's in my interest if I lock in for six
or seven years to have the ability to
say I must always be in the top 25% of
all coaches and you don't know what that
is unless you know how much they're
making but I'd want something creative
like that if I'm Josh McDaniels and he's
in the driver's seat if he's the guy
they want he you're right he's in the
driver's seat there's no doubt if he is
the guy they want
I mean it does seem like that I mean I
don't know Mike do you got a is there
another name or gut feeling you have
that makes sense for Cleveland or
anything to me right now it just seems
like it's all going in that direction
here's the name that gives me reason to
not have a strong feeling one way the
other the name is Jimmy Haslam it's not
what the hell the guy is gonna do let me
throw in Paul DePodesta as well because
the question is how much influence does
he have over the process somebody
reported last week that he's running the
coaching search and then the Browns
pushed back and said well no the house
ohms are running the coaching search D
Podesta's just coordinating well how
much sway does he have he's the guy
who's setting the table with all of the
various meal options he can present one
in a way that is more pleasing than
another and smart people like that know
how to set it up to get the person who's
making the choice where to pick and let
them think it was their choice and I
think that that's a wild card in all of
this and it may be the thing that scares
Josh McDaniels away right yes he doesn't
want to get himself into a mess he can't
be wrong this time though he can't
change his mind and once he's there he's
there so he better be damn sure this job
is gonna be what he expects it to be and
he's not gonna be interfered with by
Haslem or by D Podesta yeah you're right
I mean I think that's the the big point
right I mean this is his last chance I
mean he had a first chance with Denver
it didn't go well for a lot of different
reasons not all Josh McDaniels fall but
you're right this is it if it doesn't
work this time he'll be relegated to
position coach offensive coordinator for
the rest of his career that's what he'll
be so and the other thing you know just
knowing Josh and now like what you said
seeing Matt rule what we saw with Kyle
Shanahan I just would have a hard time
thinking Josh isn't gonna want full
control he's gonna want full control
just like Matt rule was granted and he's
gonna want to put his stamp on the way
he thinks things should be built and his
vision and everything like that
and how much of an impediment is that in
the Cleveland Browns organization I
don't know that that that is the
million-dollar question but I think if
they want Josh McDaniels they're
probably gonna have to relinquish and
give him all the power he wants and to
me football wise everything about it he
just makes the most sense
through Cleveland and I'm kind of
rooting for it at this point I kind of
want to see it done and and you want the
deal to carry enough guaranteed money so
if it doesn't work out you never have to
work again your kids never have to work
you know it gets you to your fu I'm
walking away I don't need this anymore
in the event that after you're done you
just choose to get out of it all
together you'd walk that and I think
he's in a position to ask for that
because of who he is what he's done and
how badly the Browns have bungled the
last decade of their existence the last
two decades really of their existence
yeah no exactly right and I think that's
the goal for any head football coach and
yeah just it's crazy day and I just
wonder if we're gonna be back here in a
few minutes talking about him being
hires the Cleveland Browns head coach
well the good news for you is I'm
recording PFT p.m. in two hours with MDS
so it's gonna have to happen quickly for
you to get tapped on the shoulder again
and said get your ass back in there so
we can do a third edition of PFT ot
Chris thanks to you no bra no you like
my ass I know you do really really we've
been very good we've been very well
behaved yes and yeah I've got nothing to
say to that tap you on the shoulder
that's it yeah we ivory lamb speechless
that's it for us on pft ot continue to
check in at Pro Football Talk comm all
day long we will keep you updated with
all the news and updates that go along
with the NFL mike is flummoxed right now
because I've flustered him right so
that's it for us we'll see you tomorrow
on PFT live in the morning 7:00 a.m.
Eastern to 9 a.m. Eastern
thank you okay bye bye well done okay
you